seven in ten Americans use social media
on a regular basis chances are you have
more than one site you frequent with new
ones popping up each and every day but
do you really feel fulfilled and is it
possible to get more out of your online
life good day Las Vegas anchor Heather
Mills has a look at a new app aiming to
do exactly that
our phones almost like an appendage and
when boredom Creeps in the first thing
you may be inclined to do is just start
scrolling but what are you getting out
of that and is there a way to make it
more social I'm always like on Tick Tock
or something and I'm like then I follow
them on Instagram and I'm like super
into their lives but I'm like I don't
even know them like why am I so involved
Whitney Greco is like most of us she's
on social media scrolling posting
commenting Whitney grew up with it it's
normal but as she prepares for graduate
school even she acknowledges being
plugged in all the time means you may be
actually missing out you're so connected
and tons of different ways you have to
for your like mental health just take a
breather it seems simple enough but even
better curating your use and your bubble
keeping our networks tighter helps
encourage that if I am browsing it's a
little bit more localized Dr Natalie
Pennington an assistant professor of
communication studies at UNLV has
researched multiple aspects of social
media I have a Twitter or I have an
Instagram I have a Facebook I have a
tick tock so can she answer the now
age-old question social media was not
good but social media was not bad so it
wasn't um it just kind of was in her
words it all depends on how you use it I
don't think that social media makes us
anti-social Pennington says you can
localize it and actively interact and
that's what the developers of the new
app play see are hoping you'll do we
also want to bring social back to social
media we want people to be actually able
to Foster Real Life Connections it's
Community Centric your feed is your
location everything is about your
community and it's contributed by your
community the goal to foster new
relationships within your neighbor Hood
be that a new spot to eat or shop to
visit it's inspiration at home 49 of
people you know after uh being looking
at things on social media having
interactions online they actually went
to these places in real life Pennington
says even what you may consider a minor
interaction a store clerk or Barista can
have a positive impact it's just
interacting with strangers can be really
fulfilling on our day and that can start
with social media people want to does
they have the desire to connect locally
Pennington says there is some instant
gratification and likes and follows got
new new followers but calls that passive
use a social snack but it's empty
calories because a couple hours later I
didn't actually talk to anyone so I
didn't get anything but scrolling
through something hyper local may allow
you to see things and therefore do
things and perhaps meet people in person
you wouldn't have otherwise a recent
survey that we actually you know
conducted 59 of the people who've used
social media actually have arranged
along in meeting while unplugging may
also be good Whitney says it'll take a
cultural shift to understand that it's
okay to put it away I feel like when you
do turn it off people get mad and
they're like why are you ignoring me
Heather Mills eight news now